an important use case for computer
vision and machine learning is
self-driving cars
in this course sockshae will teach you
how to implement many techniques related
to perception of self-driving cars hello
engineers i'm sakshek welcome to this
course on perception for self-driving
cars
in this course we will go over a number
of different projects that are related
to the perception module of the
self-driving car
this course is meant for an intermediate
level of audience
you are required to know the basic
concepts of python as well as some basic
concepts regarding deep learning
this course is meant for you if you are
looking to get into the field of
self-driving cars
or if you are interested to do projects
that are related to computer vision
using deep learning
before starting if you like the content
of this course you can also check out my
channel robotics with sakshe
where i post videos related to robotics
and artificial intelligence
so now let's get started
our first project would be road
segmentation in this project we would be
doing segmentation of road images using
a deep learning technique called fully
convolutional networks
in the next project we would be doing 2d
object detection on various different
traffic scenarios using a deep learning
technique called the eulo algorithm
next we will be tracking those object
detections using a technique called deep
sort
after we are done with the 2d part in
these three projects we will be moving
on to the 3d part we will start a 3d
part with 3d data visualization where we
will visualize camera images and lidar
data
next we will be discussing multi-task
learning based on two tasks depth
estimation and semantic segmentation
then we are going to move on to 3d
object detection then move on to our
final project the bird's eye view
visualization using an advanced computer
vision technique called transformers all
the data set and the code notebooks are
provided so that you can follow along
with this course
all right so what is the road
segmentation problem you would say in
road segmentation given an input image
we are required to identify where are
the roads present in this image
now we as humans can see that road is
present right over here in somewhat in
the middle of the image so what we are
required is to output an image something
that looks like this
now here we have marked the road that is
present in that image
now we aren't going to exactly output
this but what we require is that
we somehow mark this road in a separate
image
one way to do that would be
to output a black and white image where
white represents wherever the road is
present and 0 or black represents the
other background in that image
let's have a look at another image as
well
now this is another road image that we
can see now
now as humans it is easy to see where is
the road present in this image for a
computer what it would see is something
like this
so the computer has to output a
segmentation mask that looks something
like this
now these two images that you are seeing
over here are part of the kitty road
data set
now a data set is a collection of such
input images and a desired output images
which we use to baseline or check how
our model is performing
if our model is able to perform well on
these images we can be kind of sure that
they are going to perform well in real
world as well but there are some
complications that are required as well
okay so by now you would have understood
what is the problem of road segmentation
and the data set that you are working on
which is the kitty road data set now for
this task of road segmentation there
exists a number of computer vision
techniques that we can apply
the older computer vision techniques
required us the programmers to actually
hard code the different values in order
to segment the road that is present in
the image now this technique is prone to
a lot of errors and usually doesn't
generalize very good like this technique
would work for one image very good but
would completely fail for another image
for instance if we develop a technique
to segment a road on an image
then even a little shadow on the road
would completely ruin our parameter
tuning and we would require to tune the
parameters again
then with the advent of deep learning we
got rid of such hand crafting techniques
wherein the computer would automatically
learn these parameters given a diverse
set of data so one such technique that
we are going to discuss today is fully
convolutional networks now fully
convolutional networks were one of the
first techniques that introduced a
method of segmentation end to end
what i mean by end to end is that given
an input image if we feed the input
image to an fcn model it will directly
output the segmentation that it is
trained for no other preprocessing or
post processing would be required on
that image as such
now we are applying the fully
convolutional network technique on the
road segmentation task which is we can
say a subset of the segmentation task as
well
so how the complete picture looks like
is that we have an image input image
that has a road present in it we pass
that input image to the fcn model that
we have and towards the output we get a
zero one image binary image where one is
present wherever the lane was present or
the road was present otherwise we have
zero in the complete image
now in order to understand fully
convolutional networks we first need to
understand an image operation called up
sampling
so let's have a look at that
so in simple words up sampling is an
operation where we increase the size of
a given input for instance if we are
given an image like this a 2 cross 2
image then up sampling 2x is going to
double the height and the width
therefore we will be having 4 cross 4
output
the complete problem of of sampling is
we need to decide what are going to be
the values in this 4 cross 4 matrix when
we would be given the values in this 2
cross 2 given matrix
so there exist a number of techniques
that we can apply let's discuss a few of
them first the first technique for up
sampling we have is called bed of nails
what we do in bed of nails whatever the
value is present in this matrix
we are going to assign that value to
this block over here
rest of the three values that are
related to this block which are one two
three these three blocks are assigned a
value of zero similarly from this block
we can take a value and we can assign it
over here the rest three related values
are assigned zero
these which are these three similarly we
do the same thing for these two cell
values as well now this is a really
simplistic technique where we are going
to have a lot of zeros in our output
image a better method than this is the
nearest neighbor method
in nearest neighbor method what we do is
we take the value that is present over
here and in all the four related cells
to this cell we assign the same value
for instance if we have one over here we
are going to assign the value of one to
all the 4 blocks over here
similarly if we have a value of 2 over
here then we are going to assign the
value of 2 to these 4 blocks here
and we do this similarly for the
complete matrix over here
now an even better method than nearest
neighbor is called interpolation
now interpolation is more like an
average finding technique where we
assign values based on a weighted
average how we do that
in interpolation we try to work our way
backward if we want to calculate the
value of this cell over here then we
approximately try to overlap this matrix
with this matrix what we are going to
see is that this block is going to lie
somewhere over here
now this cell over here is close to four
values in this matrix which are all the
four values over here
now based on the distance from these
four values we are going to assign an
average value to this cell over here
similarly we are going to do this for
this cell as well this is going to lie
somewhere over here and average value
will be assigned to this cell based on
the
distance from the four cells that are
present over here
likewise if we want to assign the value
of this cell over here then this cell is
going to lie somewhere over here now we
are going to take the average of these
two cells only because these are the
nearest neighbors present to this cell
so this is how the interpolation method
works
now interpolation method is one of the
best technique that we could apply but
there exists an even better technique
that we can apply as well which is
transposed convolutions
in all the techniques that we discussed
before we were assigning the values
based on some heuristic that we hard
code instead in transposed convolution
we assign the values based on a
learnable weight filter
we define a filter of some size with
some random weight values we then use
those weight values to assign the value
for all the cells that are present in
this matrix and pass this to the network
when the network is going to do a back
propagation we are going to back
propagate the loss of the weights of
those filter as well and they are going
to be learned as well for the purpose of
this project i tried two methods which
were interpolation and transposed
convolutions
from what i saw transpose convolutions
did not work very well but the
interpolation method worked really well
for our case now since we have
understood what the up sampling
operation is all about so let's now
discuss the architecture of the fully
convolutional network so for the fully
convolutional network we require a
backbone network which is an image
classification network called vggnet now
what is image classification and what is
vgg net now image classification is a
problem where we are given an input
image and we are required to decide what
is present in that image
or we can say the computer is required
to decide what is present in that image
now before doing anything we already
defined the classes before sending an
input image for instance if in our image
we know that there are going to be three
entities that are present an airplane
bicycle and a person then we are going
to assign a value 0 to the airplane one
to the bicycle and 2 to the person
then we pass an image through the image
classification network and it outputs 0
1 or 2 representing what it saw in the
image now image classification is kind
of a solved problem where we have models
which give very good results on some
baseline data sets one such good network
is vggnet
now since vgcg network takes in an image
input and outputs a single number output
we need to convert it for our use case
which is the segmentation problem in the
segmentation problem the input is an
image and the output is also an image
that is of the same dimensions so let's
see the changes that we require to make
to this vgc net in order to output such
images now vgg network is composed of a
number of convolutional blocks
which are placed sequentially to each
other each convolution block consists of
two convolutional layers followed by a
max pooling layer
now what we do is we extract the output
of last three convolutional blocks which
are pool 3 pool 4 and pool 5. so what we
do first we up sample this pool 5 times
2 so we have an bigger image over here
then we add this output to the output of
pool 4 then what we get over here
we again up sample this output 2 times
to get an output over here
and finally again add this pool 3 layer
which then we get the output over here
finally we up sample this output 8 times
and the final output that we get is the
segmentation mask that we require
now this long sequence is what
constitutes the fcn architecture or
particularly this is the fcn 8
architecture
there exists two other fcn architectures
as well fcn 32 and fcn 16. what we do in
fcn32 we don't go through all these
operations that we have done over here
instead we simply up sample this pool 5
layer 32 times and we get the output in
fcn 16 we again don't do all these
operations we simply go till this step
over here where we calculate the sum
till pool 4 and then we up sample it 16
times to get the output since we are
performing all the operations that are
present over here and finally up sample
8 times therefore this architecture is
called fcn8 in one way we can say that
fcn8 is a combination of fcn32 and fcn16
what this means is that
fcn 32 identifies coarser structures in
the image fcn 16 identifies more finer
structures in the image and fcn 8 even
more finer structures in the image using
these addition operations that we have
over here we are combining the knowledge
of these three networks to get the final
output now these are the complete
details of the architecture and how this
architecture is somewhat working on the
inside
all right so now our discussion for this
is complete now let's have a look at how
this model was implemented and what are
the different results that we got so
let's have a look at that the data set
and the code both are present on kaggle
the link for both of these is in the
description you can have a look at them
as well
okay so this is the implementation first
we define an input layer with a
parameter input shape now input shape is
a tuple that contains image size image
size common number of channels image
size we have set over here is 128 cross
128 and number of channels is three the
rgb channels
then we define the vgg network but that
is vgg 16 tensorflow or keras pro
already provides us with the
implementation of vg16 which is
pre-trained on the image net data set
then we extract these three blocks which
are the pool three pool four and pool
five layers for the first step we up
sample two times that we can see over
here the tool 5 layer then we add this
up sample layer to the pool 4 and we
apply a 1 cross 1 convolution over here
as you can see now this convolution is
more like a placeholder to get the
dimensions in the right size as such
using them or not using them doesn't
have a big impact on the performance as
such
when we apply the second up sampling the
second 2x of sampling
and add that up sample layer with the
pool 3 layer
again we apply a convolution 2d which is
again as kind of a placeholder over here
finally for the output we calculate the
up sampling 8 times this final
convolution is a required one now this n
classes is said to be 1 over here this
is done because we want to set the
output of the network to be a single
channel image now that single channel is
going to contain 0 and 1 as we discussed
before one is going to be the mask where
the road is present and 0 otherwise
we also apply a sigmoid activation over
here in order to get the final values
between 0 and 1 and then we return the
model with the inputs and outputs as
such set and we have named the model
fcn8 likewise
now let's have a look at the results
that we got these images were held out
from the model and the model is seeing
them from for the first time
this is a second image
now as we can see the model is working
really well
now let's apply some changes to the
baseline network that we have and see
how the results change
now this is one change that we do
instead of the add function we are using
the concatenate function over here in
adding what we do is we add the
corresponding values that are present in
the matrix of two images
however in concatenate we just add that
image to the back of the image and
increase the number of channels of the
input
so now let's see what are the results
after we apply this concatenate instead
of add
so we can see that concatenate is also
performing good but add is a little
better than this concatenate function
now let's change that up sampling 2d
with convolutional 2d transpose which we
can see over here so instead of up
sampling here we are using transpose
convolution where we are going to learn
the weights of of sampling as well and
we are using the add function over here
so let's see how the results for this
look like
so we can clearly see that transpose
convolution is not giving that good of
results
although it has learned the task but the
output is kind of pixelated and doesn't
really look good on the segmentation as
well
all right so these are the results of
the network and some of its extensions
as well
so before discussing what is 2d object
detection problem let us first see what
is the data set that is provided to us
in this project
so lyft is a self-driving cars company
that develops self-driving car software
in order to further the research in
self-driving cars
lyft announced two competitions that
were held previously these two
competitions were 3d object detection
and motion prediction these two are
separate
the data set that we are going to use
for this project is the one from the
lift 3d object detection challenge
so what was given in the object
detection challenge
so what lyft did is it drove a
self-driving car around the streets of
palo alto and they recorded the camera
data as well as the lidar sensor data
now lidar is a sensor that works on the
principle of reflection of laser lights
a laser starting from the sensor goes
and hits an obstacle returns back to the
sensor and the sensor detects the
distance of that object so in this data
set we are given the camera data as well
as the lidar data for the same trip as
we can see these are some sample
pictures so this is one back image as we
can see we have certain cars over here
we have the front image we have certain
cars over here as well
now we can compare the lidar data with
the camera data
so we so our car is localized at this
cross
and we can see that there is one car
that is present over here that is trying
to enter the lane besides us as we can
see we also have a car over here
and we can also see that we have two
cars behind our car which are present
over here
these blue bounding boxes represent
pedestrians
so we also have front left image front
right image back right image and back
left image we can also visualize the
data in a video format so let's play
this video
similarly we can also visualize the
lidar data in a video format let's play
this video
so the code for this data visualization
will be present in the description box
below we are specifically going to work
on the camera images as such so now let
us discuss what is this object detection
problem and what is the difference
between 2d and 3d object detection so in
object detection the complete problem is
framed as such
that in a given image we are required
to find the location of an object
present in that image as well as also
tell what is that object
for instance in this example we can see
over here there is one dog that is
present and there are two cats so given
this image we need to output where is
the dog present in the form of bounding
box and where are the cats present
now in a 2d object detection case we
would be given a 2d image and we are
required to give the bounding boxes in
2d
however in 3d object detection apart
from a 2d image we would also be given
some other data representation as well
using that image and the additional data
we are required to return a 3d bounding
box
of that object along with its label
a very good example is in the 3d object
detection data as well
as we can see we are given 3d bounding
boxes of the various cars in this image
and we are also given an additional data
which is the lidar data
and we can also see that we are
predicting pedestrians as well as well
as the cars
so one cool thing that we can also
notice is that we are also able to
detect objects that are occluded in the
given image how we are able to do that
is because of the additional data that
is provided by the lidar
all right so this is all for 3d and 2d
object detection
in this video we are only going to focus
on 2d object detection so we are going
to run an algorithm on these given
images and predict 2d bounding boxes so
let's discuss that algorithm in detail
as you may have seen in object detection
we have to localize the object as well
as tell what that object is
now in case of self-driving cars as we
can see over here if we are given two
cars then we also need to find the
position of those two cars as well as
decide are they cars are they
pedestrians are there by cycles and so
on now the algorithm that we're going to
discuss for 2d object detection is
yellow
y-o-l-o and this stands for view only
look once now giving an overall picture
we can divide the yellow algorithm into
three stages which are the anchor boxes
the intersection over union and the
bounding box predictions
so how does this work now yolo is also a
deep learning technique that we use for
object detection in this we are given an
input image we pass this input image
through a convolutional neural network
and as an output we get another matrix
usually for the yellow algorithm this
matrix size is taken to be 19 cross 19.
what does this input to output mapping
represent if we consider this matrix as
a 19 cross 19 matrix if we take our
input image as such and overlap this 19
19 matrix over it then the 19 cross 19
boxes that we can see over our image all
those individual boxes are going to tell
what is present in that box
it can either be a car a truck or even a
motorcycle and it is also possible that
there is nothing useful present in that
particular box for instance in our case
it would be we can say road for each
cell we are going to have this vector in
place this thing can also be visualized
as this matrix is actually a volume so
19 cross 19 are the width and the height
of this matrix and in the depth
perspective we have this complete vector
now let's see what this vector describes
this vector that we discussed describes
the information that is present in that
particular cell the pc value is going to
tell whether something interesting is
present in that cell or not if something
interesting is not present in that cell
then the other values are just going to
be undefined or we are not going to
consider them in the calculations as
such
if we assume that pc is 1 and there is
something interesting present in that
cell then x and y are going to describe
the position of the center of that
object with respect to a given cell so x
and y are going to tell if we start from
this upper left corner of this cell how
much we need to go right and how much we
need to go down in order to reach the
midpoint of that object
w and h describe the width and height
again with respect to that cell
now these c1 c2 c3 variables describe
what object is present in that cell
for instance if we have three objects
then one of these three is going to be
one the other ones are going to be zero
if we consider that we have four objects
in our consideration then we are going
to have four variables over here c1 c2
c3 and c4
now we can see what is going to be
present in the output some of the output
cells as we can see they are read over
here are going to describe that
something special is present in that
particular cell so the output over here
gives us what the object is going to be
and what is going to be the bounding box
of that particular object one certain
example is we can see over here for this
particular car we can see that there are
multiple bounding boxes that have been
generated
by this output
and in order to differentiate i have
also drawn one car in the corner over
here as well that also has multiple
bounding boxes describing it
along with these bounding boxes and the
labels we also compute a probability
this probability also describes how much
confident are our bounding box
predictions for instance this bounding
box over here the outer one can have a
lower probability however the one that
is inside is going to have a higher
probability so this is how one part the
bounding box prediction part of euler
works
now in order to separate these bounding
boxes and get a single bounding box for
each object we use intersection over
union
and this technique of getting a single
bounding box and separating different
bounding boxes is called non-maximum
suppression
okay so first let us see what is
intersection over union or we can say
iou
so iou is used to compute how much are
two bounding boxes different
you would be able to see that in its
mathematical description
so if we have two bounding boxes as we
have given over here
we first calculate their intersection
and divide that by their union
so this gives us a measure of how two
bounding boxes are similar to each other
so we can use iou to separate the
bounding boxes of two different objects
for instance these two
we calculate the iou of the bounding
boxes with respect to the maximum
probability bounding box so what this
means if we consider again that the
inside bounding box has the highest
probability and we calculate the iou
score for the other four bounding boxes
with respect to this maximum probability
bounding box
we can see that these two bounding boxes
are going to have a very high iou value
since they have a very high iou value
this means that they are actually
representing the same object therefore
we discard these other two bounding
boxes now these two other bounding boxes
they have a very low iou value this
depicts that they represent some other
object and we are going to apply the
non-maximum separation separately on
these bounding boxes
and this is how the intersection over
union part of eulo works now there can
be a scenario in which a single cell
over here represents multiple different
objects one small example would be two
cars that are parked side by side
so in one of these cells we are going to
capture both of those cars
simultaneously
in order to deal with that problem we
use this concept of anchor boxes these
anchor boxes represent a rough shape for
the different objects that are going to
be present in our image these anchor
boxes can be designed by us humans or it
can be decided by another machine
learning algorithm as well so how does
this anchor box help in detection of
multiple objects so each anchor box
describes what shape of the object they
are looking for for instance this anchor
box is looking for a square object this
anchor box is looking for a rectangular
object with a greater height than width
and this anchor box is looking for an
object which is greater in width but
less in height each anchor box is going
to predict a certain specific object
and how this is going to change our
output
for each cell instead of having this
single vector we are going to extend
this vector in our case three times
since we have three anchor boxes
this enables us to predict multiple
objects that would be present in a
single cell
so all these techniques combined give us
the yellow algorithm yolo algorithm is a
really fast and accurate object
detection technique which makes it
extremely useful for
perception in self-driving cars there is
a lot of work that has been done on this
yolo algorithm too much so that that we
have multiple variants of yolo algorithm
with each variant of the yellow
algorithm there has been an improvement
in the speed as well as the accuracy
okay so now let's see this yolo
algorithm in action yolo is a very
complex algorithm that would take quite
a lot of time to develop hence it is
neither feasible nor an intelligent way
that we implement yolo from scratch
hence we are going to use this keras
yellow v3 implementation provided by
experience or apologies if i pronounced
it incorrectly
this is an open source implementation i
would provide the link to the repository
in the description section below this is
the notebook that we have
the link for this notebook would also be
present in the description section below
since there is nothing much to discuss
with respect to implementation we will
directly get to the results that we have
on this data set
so i have zoomed in to show the images
better as we can see the camera was
attached on a car so we are also
detecting our portion of the car as well
we are detecting other cars as well
however we can see that this bus is
getting detected as a truck
we have predictions on car as well over
here
cars over here
cars
so we can see we also have one truck
detection over here
we have the detection of a bus over here
as well and we also have a truck that is
much behind
all right so these were the results that
we got on running the yellow v3
algorithm on the lift 3d object
detection data set
now 2d object detection is pretty much a
solved problem and we already have very
good algorithms like yellow that do our
task
however there is some research that is
still required on 3d object detection
which was also the motivation behind why
lyft conducted this
competition as well all right so this is
it for this video
for this particular project we are going
to use several videos that were recorded
by a camera that was placed in front of
an autonomous car so let's have a look
at one of the videos
in this video we can see that there are
two cars that are moving
and this is another video of the same
highway scenario
so data set has six videos that contain
this highway scenario for object
tracking we need to keep track of both
of these cars that are moving in front
of us if we assign an id to both of
these cars if we say this is the black
car and this is the white car then in
each frame of the video we need to keep
detecting where is the black car and
where is the white car
this has to be done for the complete
duration of the video
in object tracking we are not only
required to detect where the car is
present in this particular frame
but we also need to remember that this
is the car that has been assigned the id
black car
and this is the car that has been
assigned the id white car
the link to this data set would be
present in the description box below
okay so now we have defined the object
detection problem and had a look at the
data set so now let us understand how
this deep sort algorithm works
as you may have seen before in object
tracking not only do we need to detect
the objects but also track where they
are going so if we consider this
collection of images or we can say a
video we can see that we have two
objects that are moving in this video it
is this round object that is going in
the horizontal direction and one object
that is going in the vertical direction
in object tracking we are not only
detecting where are the objects present
in this image
but we are also tracking where the
objects id one and two are going
so this is the whole problem of object
tracking in our case it would be traffic
tracking we need to keep a track of the
different cars that are moving around
our autonomous vehicle so the algorithm
that we are going to use to solve this
object tracking problem is called the
deep sort algorithm
before discussing the deep sort
algorithm we would first start our
discussion with the simple sort
algorithm sort stands for simple online
real-time tracking
and the simple sort algorithm uses
bounding box prediction kalman filters
and iou matching techniques
first let us start with bounding box
predictions the first step in this
algorithm is to generate bounding boxes
or detect where are the objects present
in the image now this can be
accomplished using any cnn architecture
it can be yellow it can be rcnn or it
can even be a simple computer vision
handcrafted model
for our project we have used the yolo v3
algorithm briefly what yolo v3 algorithm
does given an input image it is going to
detect all the objects that are present
in that image draw a bounding box around
them and also tell us what that object
is
after we have generated the bounding box
predictions we get to the next step
which is the kalman filter now kelvin
filter is a very broad topic which would
take an entire video to explain but
still we would be left with a lot of
ground to cover so to briefly discuss
kalman filter we can say in very simple
terms that kelvin filter is a linear
approximation so what is the role of
karman filter over here kelvin filter
needs to predict what is going to be the
future location of a given detected
object
using these future predictions we can
determine whether the object that we
were tracking isn't the same object or
not
along with that using prediction we can
also deal with the problem of occlusion
so what is occlusion
in this example above we can see between
these these two frames
the two balls are going to overlap each
other
and whichever object is in front is
going to occlude the object that is
present behind it
in order to deal with this problem in
object tracking predictions are useful
so how does kalman filter works kalvin
filter assumes a linear velocity model
and generates the predictions according
to it once we get the real data where
the object is we input that again to the
kalman filter
the kelvin filter improves its
predictions based on the real data that
it got and again generates a new set of
predictions
in this way kelvin filter works in an
iterative manner and keeps improving its
predictions
as an output the calvin filter does not
output a single number actually it
outputs a probability distribution of
where the object can be in a given set
of locations
if we take the maximum value of that
probability we can in some way
approximate where the object is going to
be this is the work of the carbon filter
it generates future predictions for the
objects
the next step we have is called iou
matching
iou stands for intersection over union
in brief terms we can say iou gives us a
quantitative score to determine how much
two bounding boxes are similar to each
other based on their location in the
image as well as the size what is this
iou matching in the context of sort
algorithm let us consider this case we
have n different cars that we are
detecting in a particular frame and we
have n ids that we need to assign to
these particular cars like in this case
ids are useful to determine which object
we are tracking so we need to assign
these n detections to these n ids for
each of the n ids we have iou score
corresponding to each detection in a
descriptive way we have the detected
objects in the row and we have the ids
in the columns so for each of the ith id
and the jth detection we have an iou
score now we want to assign the iou
scores to these end detections in such a
way that the total iou score is
maximized solving this problem using
brute force approach takes order
complexity n factorial which is very
large in order to solve this the sort
algorithm uses the hungarian algorithm
the hungarian algorithm solves this
linear assignment problem
in order complexity n cubed
which is a great improvement over the n
factorial algorithm once we have
assigned these n predictions to n ids we
have in a sense solved the tracking
problem for the ith frame then we can
run this algorithm again in a loop and
again keep track of the objects that are
in the next frame of the video so this
is how the simple sort algorithm works
now deep sort is an extension of the
simple sort algorithm now the deep in
the deep sort comes from this step
called the deep appearance descriptor
step
along with that we also have a cascade
matching step that is added to the
simple sort algorithm so deep appearance
descriptor is a convolutional neural
network which is trained to detect a
similar object in different images what
this means this
this network can tell given a number of
images of the same person in different
views whether it is the same person or
not so as an input the deep descriptor
receives a cropped image of the object
detected and as an output we try to
receive a vector that encodes the
information that is present in that
cropped image these encoded vectors
would allow us to compare different
objects
so now we have two models that are
describing us about similar objects in
different frames of a video we combine
the score given by these two models in a
linear fashion the score by the deep
descriptor is given using the cosine
distance metric and the score by the
kalman filter is given by the male and
obese distance before discussing how
these metrics are computed let us first
discuss the notion of a distance metric
a distance metric is a score that we
assigned to two different entities a and
b to tell how similar they are
for instance if we consider a 2d plane
on that plane we have two points a and b
we compute their distance from the
origin
if the two entities a and b are close to
each other then the distance from the
origin is also going to be similar in
value if the two entities a and b are
very dissimilar to each other then these
two entities are going to have a
euclidean distance that is very
dissimilar we can say one is going to
have a negative value the other one is
going to have a positive value if they
are lying on the two sides of the y axis
in these two cases we need to use
another notion of distance metric for
the deep descriptors we use the cosine
distance metric how we compute this
if we are given two entities a and b
and from the origin we draw a vector
joining these
and then we calculate the angle between
these two vectors
the cosine value of this angle is going
to give us the cosine distance metric
let us consider an example if we have
two vectors that are overlapping each
other the angle between them is going to
be 0
and the cosine value of 0 is going to be
1 this means that these two vectors are
very similar to each other
however if two vectors are perpendicular
to each other the cosine value of 90 is
going to be 0
this would mean that these two vectors
are very dissimilar to each other in
this way we would be able to determine
whether the two objects that we detected
how much similar they are to each other
for the kalman filter case we are not
using the cosine similarity the reason
for this is the kalman filter is going
to output not a single point but a
probability distribution in order to
compare the similarity between a point
and a probability distribution we use
melon obvious distance
if we consider that this is the
distribution that is output by the
kelvin filter this implies that the
probability of the object being over
here is very high compared to the values
outwards
and this is the point that we want to
compare with this probability
distribution
in very simple terms what myelin obvious
distance does for a 2d version we
compute the two directions in which the
data spread is the highest for this case
we can see the data spread is the
highest in this direction and a
perpendicular this direction
then we normalize and transform the
coordinate axis in such a way that these
two axis become the coordinate axis
in that transformed space we calculate
the distance of this point from the
origin the value of that distance is the
melanobus distance
using this metric we decide how much a
given prediction by the kalman filter
matches an object that we just detected
combining these two we get an overall
scalar score value that we can use to
assign the detections to their ids using
the hungarian algorithm however in the
implementation there is a slight catch
the authors of the deep sort
algorithm noticed that the predictions
by the kalman filter are not very useful
and the score for these predictions can
be neglected however you would see that
in our project this doesn't work very
well the next step that we have is
cascade matching cascade matching is an
extension to the iou matching algorithm
for the assignment problem the cascade
matching takes into account the temporal
dimension as well in order to reduce the
time complexity for the hungarian
algorithm cascade matching tries and
match the latest detections with the
latest ids and the later or old
detections with the old ids all of this
process combined gives us the deep sort
algorithm
and we can again run this algorithm in a
loop to track objects in a complete
video
all right so this is all for the
explanation part of the deep sort
algorithm now let's have a brief look at
the code and the results and see how it
worked for our project so let's do this
the link to this code or notebook will
be provided in the description box below
as well
so these are the different sub parts of
the complete deep sort algorithm the
first part is the eulo v3 network that
is used to generate the bounding boxes
the second step is the detections part
where we encode the given cropped image
the third part is the kalman filter
where we use the kelvin filter to
generate the predictions
the next part is the iou matching in
this part we solve the linear assignment
problem
and the cascade matching that we
discussed before
next up is the nearest neighbor matching
this contains the code for the euclidean
distance as well as the cosine distance
the next part is tracking this combines
all the different modules that we
developed before to create a final
object that does the complete tracking
finally we have the object tracking
where we run the complete algorithm this
file over here contains the pre-trained
network for deep appearance descriptor
we have this function object tracking
that takes in the video path input and
also takes the output path where to save
the output video now let's have a look
at the results of how the final video
looks like
so this is the first video as we can see
this one and two these are the ids that
are assigned to these two cars
respectively
this is the second video
as we can see the car over here was
assigned the id 9 and even in some
frames the yellow algorithm was not able
to detect that car
even after those miss detections the
algorithm was able to determine that
this was the car labeled id9
till now we had a look at the videos
where the algorithm was performing
really well now let's have a look at the
video where the algorithm didn't perform
that well
in this video we can see that we have
this car labeled 12
and we have this new car that is labeled
35 now you will see what is the problem
that this algorithm is facing
due to the occlusion that was given by
this black car
this car is now re-identified as the id
36 and not the id
12 that it was assigned before
so this is one problem that deep sort
algorithm faced due to a longer
occlusion period the algorithm was not
able to detect
the correct id for the car
even after checking different hyper
parameter values i was not able to get
rid of this id assignment problem
this i believe would be due to
assigning a negligible amount of weight
to the kelvin filter predictions
possibly if we increase the weight for
the kelvin filter predictions this
problem would be solved
but that is an extension to the project
that we developed in this video and will
be looked as a future work to this
project
all right so this is it for this video
okay so these are the images that are
part of the kt3d object detection data
set as we can see
and these are the lidar data provided in
the data set as well
for instance we can see a wall in this
image over here the same wall it has a
correspondence in the lidar scan as well
as we can see over here
these curvy lines are the projections of
the lidars that fell on the road itself
also if we consider another example we
can see this car in front of the
image this same car can be seen over
here
which is blocking the lidar signals
another cool visualization that we have
is the lidar data presented in the form
of a camera
as we can see over here
as we saw in the image earlier we had a
car in front of us we can see that car
similarly in these lidar scans as well
another example is this car over here
this car this car as well as the traffic
signal can be seen in this lidar scan as
well
and this is another visualization of the
lidar data as well as the bounding box
that are given in that 3d object
detection data set
all right so these are all the
visualizations
now let us understand what is the theory
behind how we generate these
visualizations
okay now in order to understand how are
we generating these data visualizations
first up we need to understand the
concept of homogeneous transformations
in a general self-driving car setting we
usually have two main sensors which are
lidar and the camera
typically these lidar and camera sensors
are not going to be placed at the same
location they are going to have
different locations on a car for
instance in this case the lidar is on
top of the car and the camera is on the
front head of the car
camera as we all know is a visual sensor
we use it to capture a 2d scene of a
given 3d environment
lidar on the other hand is a perception
sensor it is used to map a 3d
environment using a rotating laser lidar
generates what are called the point
clouds
point clouds provide a very good
representation of a given 3d environment
now this is a very general use case that
we want to see the data that was
captured by a lidar in the frame of a
camera what i mean by that if through
our eyes we are seeing how the
environment is looking like from here
we also need to see how the same
environment at the same time is going to
look like when we see it from over here
at the camera location
in order to convert between these given
reference points we use what are called
homogeneous transformations if we
consider that we are given two
coordinate axes the blue one over here
and this red one over here and we have
this object this black dot that we want
to see through both of these coordinate
axis
mathematically this problem translates
to
if we are given the vector from the
origin of this coordinate axis to this
point over here which we call x
we need to find x dash which is a vector
starting from the origin of this
coordinate axis to the same point given
this coordinate axis is called
transformation
now any general transformation can be
divided into two sub problems which are
translation and rotation
translation is simply moving the origin
of this coordinate axis to some other
location in space
if we have a coordinate axis like this
and we simply move this to a new
location then we have what is called a
translation
in rotation however we would like to
change the direction in which these axis
are pointing
however the origin is going to remain at
the same place in order to understand
rotation better we can divide the
rotation operation into three sub
operations which are rotation about the
x axis rotation about the y axis and
rotation about the z axis
a combination of all these three
rotations gives us the actual rotation
that is going to finally take place
without going into much depth let us see
how the mathematical representations of
these look like
in order to get the translated vector we
simply need to add another vector to our
original vector
in this case we are adding this abc
vector to our original x to get x t
which is the translated vector
the rotation operation can be understood
as a matrix multiplication
if we consider this 3 cross 3 matrix and
we multiply this matrix with our
original vector x we get a rotated
vector x r
however we need to keep this in mind
the values of this translation vector
can be taken anything but the parameters
of this matrix are
bounded between a range
combining these two sub operations of
translation and rotation we get what is
called a homogeneous transformation
what homogeneous transformation does
it simply reduces translation and
rotation into a single matrix
multiplication as we can see over here
so how we derive this matrix multiplier
first up we take the rotation matrix and
place it in the upper left corner over
here we take this translation vector we
place it in the upper right corner over
here and the remaining part this last
row is filled with three zeros and a one
this would look something like this
this three cross three matrix is the
rotation matrix and this three
dimensional vector is the translation
vector rest zeros and ones are placed
over here
now following the rules of matrix
multiplication given this is a 4 cross 4
matrix it can only be multiplied with a
vector of dimensionality 4.
in order to make this 3 dimensional
vector a 4 dimensional vector what we do
is place a 1 over here
hence our complete operation looks like
this we take this matrix we multiply
this matrix with this extended vector
and what we get as an output is this
extended vector over here
because of the structure of this matrix
over here this one over here is a
guaranteed number
using this operation we finally get a
vector x dash representing the point x
in a new frame of axis
now in order to convert this given 3d
data into a 2d representative screen
just like we have in a camera we use the
operations that we will discuss over
here now mathematically how does a
camera work
if we consider this red coordinate axis
as the camera axis
we have this point in the 3d scene that
we can see through this camera axis
now we define a new point which is
called the camera center which is taken
to be the origin of this coordinate axis
over here now all the points that are
situated at a distance of one unit from
this camera center in the direction of z
axis
is what we call the image plane
now this image plane is a plane 2d
surface which has defined its x and y
coordinates in this direction the x
direction is taken upward and y
direction is taken along this direction
we can also understand this image plane
as
sitting at the camera center
and watching a cinema screen that is one
unit away from us
now this complete problem boils down to
if we are given this 3d point we want to
project this 3d point to this image
that is how would this 3d point look
like if we were to see it in a
2d projected image plane
and this is exactly what a camera does
converts a 3d scene into a 2d image
we accomplish this using the similar
homogeneous transformations
if we are given a transformation matrix
m we can simply multiply that with our
3d object vector x dash and get a new
vector which is x double dash
also in order to get how these points
would look like in this image plane
we need to divide the x and y
coordinates of this newly x double dash
vector with its z coordinate which we
can see over here
solving both of these operations we
would get the transformation of a 3d
point on a 2d image plane
in our case how that works out if we are
given the point cloud that is generated
by the lidar using these operations
we can see how that lidar point cloud is
going to look like when we put it on an
image that is generated by a camera
now this complete concept of homogeneous
transformations is very fundamental to
robotics as well as computer vision
it is used in self-driving cars mobile
robots and even robot manipulators
in computer vision apart from this
application it is also used in 3d scene
reconstruction
now the parameters used for the
operations that we did on this side of
the board are called extrinsic
parameters
and the parameters that we used for this
side of the board are called intrinsic
parameters
extrinsic parameters are external to the
camera and depend on how the camera is
placed
intrinsic parameters depend on the
internals of a camera for instance the
focal length of the camera lens
there are a number of different ways we
can use to determine what are the
extrinsic and the intrinsic parameters
of a given camera
one very popular way to determine these
is the checkerboard method
in this method we take a printed photo
of a chess or a checkerboard and we
click its images in different positions
and angles
we apply a number of different
operations to those images to determine
the extrinsic and the intrinsic
parameters of the camera
this is all the theory that we needed to
discuss
for the data visualization now let's
have a brief look at the code of how
this data visualization is working so
let's get to it all the code that we are
using to generate these 3d
visualizations will be present in the
description box below as well
alright so now first let us discuss how
we generate this
lidar data in the form of a camera
in order to convert we have this points
array over here this array contains all
the points of the point cloud that were
captured by the lidar
we pass this points array
to a function called velo to cam
along with that we also pass the
extrinsic camera matrix
value to cam over here stands for
velodyne 2 camera
velodyne is the lidar sensor that was
used over here
all in all what this fellow to cam
function does
it takes this cloud array and it takes
this v to c matrix and it simply does a
matrix multiplication on them
once we get the points in the camera
reference
we then calculate a matrix
multiplication of those points with the
intrinsic camera matrix
and we do the division operation over
here
and finally we fill in different colors
using this expression over here
and calling this function on different
set of point clouds gives us this the
following visualization that we see over
here
generating this view of the lidar also
called the bird's eye view is relatively
simple
we simply take the points of the point
cloud
and scale them in such a way that they
occupy the complete frame of a given
image
and then finally fill the different
colors that are present in over here
and this is how we get the bird's eye
view of the lidar data
getting this image visualization is
pretty simple
and this data is already provided and we
do not need to do any processing over
here as such
getting the boxes to print over here is
also simple just like how we did for the
lidar
we use the extrinsic and intrinsic
camera parameters to accomplish the same
and this is just a combined view of the
lidar and the boxes
all right so this is all for this video
all right so the problem of multi-task
learning is such that we want to derive
a single network that can be used for
various different computer vision tasks
the data set that we are going to use
for this particular project is the
cityscapes dataset the link for this
data scrap would be present in the
description box below the cityscape
dataset consists of different street
view images
that is images taken from a car that is
being driven on the road
this data set is particularly used for
depth estimation and semantic
segmentation let's have a look at the
images present in the data set and what
these two tasks are
so these are the different images that
are present in the data set
okay now let us discuss what is the
depth estimation task as the name
implies in this task we want to
calculate the depth of any object that
is present in the image
let us have a look at some of the
example images to make this point more
clear
in this image we have this truck that is
front of our car
and through the color gradient we can
see that the depth is almost constant in
front of this
we can also observe other such features
from this gradient color
the areas close to the car are slightly
darker in color and as we move away from
the car the colors get slightly lighter
as we can see over here
a similar look we can have over here
there is a car present near our car and
we can see a very dark color for that
car
and as the objects go away the color
gets lighter and lighter let's have a
look at some more example images
so the overall work in this task is to
calculate depth maps
and the depth maps without the
underlying image look something like
this
for the image segmentation task we need
to segment different objects that are
present in the image let's have a look
at some example images in this example
all the cars and vehicles are segmented
in a yellow color
and the trees and background are
segmented in red color
something similar can be observed in
this image as well let's have a look at
other example images as well
so the overall work in this task is to
calculate segmentation labels
which we can see in the example images
over here
all right so this is the visualization
of the data that we are going to use
now let us have a look at the technique
that we are going to use to solve the
multi-task learning problem
all right so the problem of multi-task
learning is as follows
we want to derive a network that can be
used to solve different tasks these
different tasks can be object detection
object classification and object
segmentation
the constraint in this problem is that
we cannot have different networks for
these different tasks we have to use a
single network that is run once and
trained once to solve all the different
tasks the advantage it has over
distributed networks is that we don't
have to train each and every network
individually for the different tasks
resulting in saving some time so the
technique that we are going to discuss
for this multitask learning is m10 m10
stands for multi-task attention network
and this is the architecture that m10
follows given an input image the first
step we do is calculate the shared
features of that given input image
then we have task specific modules that
use those shared features to solve their
given task
for n number of tasks we are going to
have n specific attention modules these
attention modules take some data from
the shared features
and augment it in such a way
that is useful for their particular task
the word attention over here refers to
the attention that each module gives to
its particular task
for the m10 technique we can use any
convolutional network to calculate the
shared features
for our particular project we are going
to use segnet to calculate the shared
features
now segnet is a network that is used to
solve the image segmentation task in the
image segmentation task we would be
given an input image and the task is to
segment the different objects that are
present in that image
for this image segmentation task the
networks that are used have a general
structure the general structure is such
that we are given an input image the
first step we do is down sample the
image and derive the features from that
image once we downsample the image and
reach the bottleneck we upsample the
image to the same dimension as the given
input image and with the help of the
features derived in the downsampling
task output a segmentation mask
the downsampling part of the network is
also called the encoder and the
upsampling part of the network is also
called the decoder
the only difference between segnet and
fully convolutional neural networks is
the operation that we use for up
sampling
so the segment architecture has
different convolution blocks as we can
see over here
these convolution blocks comprise of
convolution layers followed by some
pooling layers
now the m10 architecture is in such a
way that for each of these convolution
blocks we have attention sub modules
these sub modules are for the blue task
and these sub modules are for the red
task
the arrows over here show the data flow
that is happening between the overall
network
now there are some differences in the up
sampling attention modules and the down
sampling attention modules
let us discuss them in slight detail
for the up sample attention module
we get the input from the previous
attention module which we can see over
here
and we take another input that is
derived from the first layer of the
convolution block as we can see over
here
these two matrices are merged
the convolution operation on them is
computed twice
and then we calculate the element wise
multiplication of the output generated
over here
and the input of one of the filters of
this convolution blocks as we can see
over here
then this element-wise multiplication is
once again sent through a convolution
block and the output is returned to the
next attention module for the down
sampling module we
we take the input from the previous
tension module which we can see over
here
this input is sent through a convolution
block which is then merged with the
input of the first layer of the
convolution block which is present over
here
this merged filter is passed twice
through convolution blocks
then an element-wise multiplication is
calculated for this output and the input
that is taken from one of the layers of
convolution block as we can see over
here
and this final output is sent to the
next attention module the tension module
is only different for the up sampling
and down sampling phase of the shared
feature network
for the different tasks the attention
module architecture is exactly the same
and this is the complete network
architecture of the m10 network
one additional technique that m10
proposes is what is called dynamic
weight averaging
for any multi-task learning network
we calculate the loss by a weighted
average of the loss calculated for the
different tasks as we can see over here
the adjustment of the weights of these
losses is very important for the network
to actually converge and learn the
different tasks
dynamic weight averaging is a technique
that is used to determine these weights
based on the rate of change of the
gradient loss now what is the rate of
change of gradient loss if we consider
two training batches of images input to
the network at time t and time t plus 1
the difference between the loss that is
back propagated at time t plus 1 and
time t is what is called the rate of
change of gradient loss
we calculate these weight values by
taking a soft max kind of average using
the rate of change of loss and this
technique gives us the optimal value of
the weights that we should have for
these individual losses
so these are the two main contributions
of the multi-task attention network
technique
so this is all the theory that we need
to cover for the m10 technique now let
us have a brief look at the code and the
results generated using this technique
okay so the code or notebook for this
m10 would be present in the description
box below as well
so the first thing that we have done
over here is implement the data set
loader class which we can see over here
now this data set loader class is
specific to the cityscapes data set
the architecture that we discussed can
be applied to a number of different data
sets and for those data sets we would
have to implement those specific classes
then we have defined the utility
functions
model fit which is used to train the
model
we also have the different metrics the
confusion matrix
and the depth error
and then we have this function called
multitask trainer
which handles the complete training of
the network
we have also defined the network in this
segnet class
finally we load the data set and train
it on the data set
one thing to note is that the authors of
this technique trained the network on
200 epochs with a learning rate of 10
raised to power -4
however due to the constraints imposed
by kaggle on the training time doesn't
allow us to experiment with these values
hence for this particular experiment the
epochs are taken to be 100 and the
learning rate is taken to be 10 raised
to the power minus 3.
the results of the training are decent
and good
however
it would have been better if we use the
parameters that were provided by the
authors
let us have a look at some of the
results the left one is the original
segmentation map and the right one is
the predicted segmentation map
as we can see there are slight issues
that this network faces while segmenting
by cycles
but the overall results do look good
these are the segmentation results
overlaid on the image
now let's have a look at the depth maps
the left one is the original depth map
and the right one is the predicted depth
map
for the depth map we can also say there
are slight errors here and there but the
results overall do seem good
now these are the depth maps overlaid on
the image
all right so this is it for this video
all right so the data set that we are
going to use for this video is the kitty
3d object detection data set we will
quickly go over this data set in this
video as well
this data set has images that are taken
from the front camera of a self-driving
car as we can see them over here
we are also provided with a lidar data
that was captured by lidar present on
the self-driving car as we can see them
over here
and these are the lidar data projected
in the view of a camera
so this is the data set that we are
going to work with
now the cool thing about sfa 3d
technique is that
this network only uses the lidar data to
do the 3d object detection task
hence the images that are present in
this data set are not used at all
another thing to note as well
this data that we are visualizing over
here is a processed form of the kt3d
object detection data set
however for generating the final output
of the technique
we are going to use the raw form of the
kt data set that is provided in the form
of a video feed
the real time video feed and the lidar
data field would be used for the final
prediction task
all right so this is all for the data
set now let us discuss the technical
details of this sfv 3d technique
okay so as we discussed we are going to
use sfa 3d for the 3d object detection
task
sfa 3d stands for super fast and
accurate 3d object detection
so sfa 3d as a complete technique
does 3d object detection using only the
lidar data
as an input we provide sfa 3d as a
bird's eye view input image to the
network
the network predicts the different
objects that are present in that image
and also classifies them as well
the data collected using a lidar is a 3d
data when we view that 3d data from a
top view that top view is also called
the bird's eye view of that given scene
once you provide the network with the
bird's eye view image of the lidar scene
as an output we get seven outputs
these seven outputs are
heat maps of the different classes that
are present in the image
the distance of the center of other
objects from our ego car or the
self-driving car
the angles in which the other objects
are facing
the dimensions of the objects that we
have detected the length breadth and the
height
and the z-coordinate of the center of
that object as we can see over
here so now we have discussed the input
as well as the list of outputs that sfa
3d provides us
now sfa 3d mainly consists of three
components which are key point fpn
the different losses that we are going
to use for this network and the learning
rate scheduling technique that we employ
for the training
let us discuss these techniques one by
one
the first component that we are going to
discuss is the key point fpn
before discussing key point fpn let us
first discuss what is fpn
fbn stands for feature pyramid network
feature pyramid network is a feature
extraction technique that given a single
input image outputs different feature
maps that vary in size
it's something as we can see over here
given a single input image the outputs
are different feature maps of different
sizes so what is feature extraction and
feature maps all the important data that
is contained inside an image is what are
called features they can be points edges
designs and patterns or even human faces
in a convolutional neural network we
have what are called convolution blocks
these convolution blocks consist of
different convolution layers and cooling
layers
we provide an input image to these
convolution blocks and we get an output
image or we can say a matrix this output
image or matrix are what are called
feature maps the process of extracting
features out of a given image is what is
called feature extraction now feature
pyramid networks is not a network by
name it's actually a general technique
that we can employ on a number of
different neural networks
for instance we can apply this feature
pyramid network technique to generate
feature maps on a resnet architecture as
well by post processing these output
feature maps we can do a number of
different tasks like object detection
the feature pyramid network technique
works in this way
given this input image we pass it
through a number of different
convolution blocks and ensure that these
images get smaller in size
as we can see over here the input image
is getting smaller in size as we
approach the tip of the pyramid
then we employ successive iterations of
convolution blocks ensuring that they up
sample the given image as we can see
over here
the image gets larger in size as we
approach the base of the pyramid network
along with the convolutions that we
apply in this part of the network we
also
provide information to this part of the
network from the previous part of the
network as we can see through the skip
connections over here
and we generate the output feature maps
from this part of the network as we can
see over here
now feature pyramid networks are a great
technique to employ if we want to create
networks that are scale in variant
so what is scale in variant network
let us assume that we want to predict a
ball that is present on an image using a
simple convolutional network if the ball
that is present in that image of large
size or that ball is of small size the
neural network should be able to detect
the ball that is present in that image
this property of detecting irrespective
of the size of that object is what is
called scale in variance
for tasks like object detection we need
to predict a bounding box that tells us
where that object is present in that
image
for tasks like these scale invariance is
an important property that neural
networks are supposed to have
however for detecting points in a given
image scale in variance does not play a
major role
if we want to detect a single point in a
given image that point is going to
remain at the same location irrespective
of the scaling that we apply on that
image hence directly applying feature
pyramid networks to detect points in an
image is not an efficient technique
key point feature pyramid networks are
an extension to the given fpn networks
that help us detect points in a given
image
the overall architecture of key point
fpl remains the same
the outputs of the fpn can be visualized
as we can see over here
these gaussian shaped outputs that we
see over here
indicate that the network is really
confident that a point is present at a
given location in the image but as we
move away from that point the confidence
level of the network goes down as we can
see from the shape over here
so once we have these feature output
maps we convert these feature maps to a
similar size
in this particular case we have taken
the reference size to be the largest
feature map that is present with us
we up sample the smaller feature maps to
match the size of the largest feature
map that we have as we can see in this
column over here
then we calculate a weighted average of
these feature maps and get a final
single output as we can see over here
the weights of the weighted average are
dependent on the confidence value that
the network has in this different
feature maps
from this feature map we can take the
point that has the highest confidence
value and output that as the point that
we wanted to detect
this complete post processing that we
have done after the simple fpn network
is what constitutes the keypoint fpn
network
all right so this is the complete
network architecture of the sfa 3d
technique now let us discuss the
different loss functions that are
employed to train this network
first off we are going to discuss the
outputs that are generated by this
network
the first output is a heat map of the
different classes heat map is a data
visualization technique that tells us
the magnitude of a given phenomena
occurring on a given input roughly we
can visualize a heat map using a
mountain terrain
usually in a mountainous range we have a
mountain that has the highest peak and
has accompanying hills or mountains that
are of smaller peaks than this highest
peak mountain
as we move away from this highest peak
the height of the ground also starts
decreasing in all the directions
something like this
as we move away from that highest peak
we approach another neighboring mountain
or a hill
after the height decreases the height
again starts increasing until we reach
the top or the peak of the neighboring
mountain
and once again as we move away from that
peak the height again starts decreasing
if we view such a mountainous region
from the top view
and visualize the height of the ground
in that image we get what is called a
heat map
if we denote a larger height by a dark
red color and a lower height by a white
color
we are going to observe that the highest
peak has a solid red color as we move
away from that peak that solid red color
is going to decay into a white color
again as we approach another peak that
white color is going to converge into a
solid red color again
a heat map can also be visualized in
terms of confidence of a network that it
has on its predictions
in our particular case if we want to
detect three objects let's say a car a
truck and a pedestrian we are going to
generate three different heat maps
in this case the red color denotes that
there is a car that is present in that
image at this particular location and
the network is confident about this
location
similarly a pedestrian is present in
this location and the network is
confident about its prediction in this
particular location
as we move away from both these
locations the confidence of the network
goes down
using this heat map we detect the class
of the object whether it is a car or a
pedestrian
in order to encourage the network to
learn the right classes we use what is
called a focal loss
the mathematical expression of the focal
loss is something like this
focal loss is usually used when there
exists a class imbalance in the data
class imbalance usually occurs when
there is a less amount of data for a
particular class and a very high amount
of data for another particular class
here pt is the confidence value of the
network this scaling factor over here
allows the network to focus its learning
more on the predictions that it is less
confident about and focus less on the
predictions that it is more confident
about
next output we have are
the distance from the ego card and the
direction in which the other objects are
facing in order to learn this we use
what is called an l1 loss the
mathematical expression is something
like this
l1 loss simply takes the difference of
the prediction and the actual value and
computes the absolute value of that
difference
the next output that we have are the
dimensions of the object we are trying
to detect
and its z coordinate the distance or the
height from the ground
in order to learn these four parameters
we use what is called a balanced l1 loss
now given a training data we can divide
the points in that data roughly into two
categories
outliers and in layers while training a
network the data points that generate a
loss value that is less than some
threshold let us say one are called in
liars
and
the data points that have a loss that is
greater than that threshold are called
outliers
due to a larger value of loss the
outliers tend to attract
the neural network weights towards
itself
due to a smaller loss value the
in-layers are not able to attract the
neural network weights towards itself
that sufficiently well
in order to efficiently deal with such
an imbalance of loss values we use what
is called a balanced l1 loss
the balanced l1 loss balances the loss
values that are generated by both of
these in-layers and outliers to get a
network that performs well on both these
types of data
all right so these are all the losses
that are used in this network the next
component that we are going to discuss
is the learning rate scheduling
while training a neural network the
learning rate is an important hyper
parameter that we need to take care of
a particular technique that we apply to
better train a network is called
learning rate scheduling during the
training process we tend to decrease or
increase the learning rate values in
order to fine tune our optimization
process
the learning rate decay technique that
we use in this
network is the cosine annealing
the graph of the learning rate in cosine
annealing looks something like this
towards the start the learning rate
decreases slowly towards the middle the
learning rate starts decreasing in a
linear fashion
and towards the end the learning rate
decrease again starts to slow down
the combination of all these three
components is what constitutes the sfa
3d technique alright so these are all
the technical details there are to
discuss for the sfa 3d technique
now let us see this algorithm in action
ok so let us have a brief look at the
code
the link to this code and the notebook
will be provided in the description box
below as well
the first step that we have is the
configuration step here we set up the
different parameters and variables that
we are going to use for our network
next up we have the different data
processing functions that we use
one such data processing technique is to
convert the lidar data into a bird's eye
view of the given data
next up we have different utility
functions like logging that we use to
log the training process
learning great scheduling that we use
while training the network and different
visualization utility functions that we
use to visualize and generate the final
output
next up in this section we define the
different loss functions that we are
using to train the network
finally we define the fpn resnet network
over here in this section
and in this section we finally train the
neural network
one particular problem that 3d object
detection network face
is training
the training of these networks is really
time consuming and require very
expensive and good quality hardware
since we have a time limit and some
constraints on hardware on kaggle
i was not able to train the network by
myself
hence i have used the pre-trained
weights that are provided along with
this network architecture
so now let us have a look at the final
output so this is the final output that
we have on the rod dataset for the
purpose of visualization i have slowed
down this video
okay so some key observations that we
can note over here
red boxes describe the cars that are in
the scene
blue bounding boxes are for cyclists
that are present in the scene and yellow
bounding boxes are for pedestrians on
the given scene
one interesting observation is that the
network is not able to detect the tram
that is present in this image
since it was not trained on that data
also these blue lines describe
the orientation of the various
surrounding cars
all right so this is all that is to
discuss of the sfa 3d technique
so let us start with the problem
definition
in this problem given a set of images
taken from the different cameras present
on a self-driving car or a robot we are
required to process these images and
output a bird's eye view of the given
environment
bird's eye view or top view are viewing
the 3d scenes from the top
as an input we can either have a single
image or we can have multiple different
images taken from the different cameras
in this case we can see this is our
self-driving car and in this case for
our particular problem we have four
cameras in the front left right and the
back
given these four images we are required
to process them and output the bird's
eye view of the environment around the
car as we can see over here the red
rectangle is the ego car or our
self-driving car and the other blue
rectangles are the other cars now why do
we require to calculate this bird's eye
view of the environment
there are mainly two reasons we would
like to calculate the bird's eye view
the first application is object
detection
calculating a bird's eye view of the
given environment provides us with a
different way of doing object detection
compared to other different computer
vision methods
the second or the more important
application is path planning
this bird's eye view provides us with a
concise representation of the
surrounding environment the different
cars and objects that are present in the
scene and the road that we are required
to go on
using this concise representation we can
easily implement path planning
algorithms on our self-driving car
so this is the complete introduction to
the problem statement now let us have a
look at the data set that we are going
to work with in this project
all right so the link to this data and
this data visualization notebook would
be provided in the description box below
just like in the problem description
we are given four images the front the
rear left and right along with that we
are given certain bird's eye view images
now the images that we have been given
are not exactly real time images but
semantics segmented images
we already have the different classes in
these images semantically segmented and
we have to derive a bird's eye view
image for the same
the cool thing about this data set is
that the data site is derived from a
simulation the self-driving car drives
around the simulation environment and we
capture the different images from the
four different cameras that are present
on the self-driving car a drone flies
just above a self-driving car in order
to capture the ground truth bird's eye
view images
as we can see we have these four images
taken from the self-driving car cameras
the front image the rear image the left
image and the right image
and this is the ground truth bird's eye
view image of the 3d environment
this next image the bird's eye view
occlusion image contains occlusion as a
separate class
this means that the scene that is hidden
or occluded by different objects in the
environment
are represented using a separate class
as we can see in this gray color over
here
this car present behind a self-driving
car is blocking the view of the camera
in this gray space
additionally some buildings are also
occluding the space as we can see over
here and due to this occlusion we are
not able to see this car that is present
behind the building and is not visible
through our camera
this homography image is similar to the
bird's eye view image that we have over
here but contains a lot of noise
so what is a homography operation
in simple terms using a homography
operation we can convert from one image
plane to another image plane
in this particular case we are
converting from these four images the
front rear left and right and using
these to generate a bird's eye view
image
this bird's eye view conversion
operation is also called inverse
perspective mapping
more on this homography and inverse
perspective mapping will be discussed in
the later part of the video and we will
understand why we do not use this
technique directly to derive the bird's
eye view image
now let us have a look at few instances
of this data set
yes
all right so the technique that we are
going to apply to solve this problem is
unit xst
as the name suggests this technique is
an extension of the unit semantic
segmentation architecture
therefore the unit xst has two
components the unit architecture itself
and its extension let us discuss the two
components one by one so the first
component is the unit network
unit is a network that is used for
semantic segmentation in the problem of
semantic segmentation we are required to
segment a region of interest from a
given image for instance in an image
captured by a self-driving car we are
required to segment the cars that are
present in the image and the road that
is present in the image
we can do so by highlighting them with
different colors
the unit architecture is similar to
other semantic segmentation
architectures where we have an encoder
part of the network and we have the
decoder part of the network
the encoder part downsamples the image
deriving different visual features in
the image and then we have the decoder
part which upsamples the image and
returns us the output
apart from the information derived from
the decoder part itself the decoder uses
information from the encoder part using
skip connections as we can see over here
initially unit architecture was devised
for biomedical image segmentation
however its use cases applies to other
domains as well for instance in our case
self-driving cars
unite forms the basic architecture for
this technique
now let us discuss the xst or the
extension part of the unit network
the extension part of the technique is
that we make use of what are called
spatial transformers
so before discussing what are spatial
transformers let us discuss the concept
of homography
for instance we have an object and we
take its image from a camera that is
placed over here we change the camera
position as well as its orientation to
something over here and we take the
image again
the transformation between these two
images is what is called homography
in mathematical terms homography is a
simple matrix multiplication
a cool application of homography is that
if we know the homography matrix that
converts from one image plane to other
image plane
then from a single image we can directly
compute how that object would look like
in a separate image plane without even
taking a different picture
however in application we would require
those image planes to be close to each
other
in general the transformation need not
be that complex
they can be as simple as translating the
camera plane or even rotating the camera
plane at a given fixed point
for instance given this image we are
rotating the image plane by
approximately 15 degrees
now theoretically it would seem that we
can simply take an image x multiply it
by a homography matrix h and get the
final resulting image hx
however it is not that simple
in simple terms homography is a simple
transformation that maps pixels from one
image to another image
hence what we would have is this image
pixel mapped to some image pixel in this
image over here
on doing this matrix multiplication it
is easy to observe that the output h x
is not going to output integer values
what this means is that a given pixel
over here is going to map to a number of
different pixels over here
hence in order to apply this
transformation we are going to have a
lot of different average calculations
making the final image look not really
good
hence a solution to this is to do an
inverse homography calculation what that
means instead of computing a
transformation that goes from input to
output we instead calculate a
transformation that goes from the output
pixel to the input pixels for instance
this output pixel over here is going to
map to the input image in a rotated
fashion something like this over here
we calculate an average of the
surrounding pixels in the input image
for instance this pixel is going to map
to surrounding these four pixels over
here hence we are going to calculate
their weighted average pixel values to
derive the value of this pixel
this weighted average is calculated
using a technique called
bilinear interpolation
the weighted average is taken with
respect to the distance from the
surrounding pixels
in place of bilinear interpolation we
can apply other different techniques
like linear interpolation or nearest
neighbors as well
however for spatial transformers
bilinear interpolation is the choice due
to its differentiable nature so having
understood this complete process of
homography
let us discuss the use of this
homography in a spatial transformer
spatial transformer is an extension
module that can be applied to any
convolution network this enables the
convolution network to also learn the
different spatial properties that are
present in the data set
the spatial transformer learns the
different parameters of the homography
matrix in order to aid the convolution
network
in the same example if we have an object
over here and we take its image from
this point
and let us assume for some reason the
cnn architecture is not able to classify
this object accurately how spatial
transformers are going to help the
spatial transformers are going to learn
the homography matrix parameters in such
a way that they present an image to the
cnn from a different point so that the
cnn is able to classify that object
more accurately
so having understood what is a spatial
transformer and how it helps
let us see how we apply this to our unit
xst technique
for the unit xst technique we are not
going to learn the parameters of the
homography matrix
instead we are going to provide the
spatial transformers with a fixed
homography matrix
so where do we get these homography
parameters
since homography is a general
application we can also apply this to a
self-driving car scenario as well
for instance given this image from a
right facing camera we can easily derive
a homography that maps from this right
camera to a virtual camera that is
present at the top
we can do this for all the four cameras
and derive a top view of the environment
in this way we would easily get the
homography parameters
this technique of deriving the top view
from these given images is also called
inverse perspective mapping
but there's a natural question to ask
why we apply complex network
architectures like unit xst whereas we
can solve our problem using simple
homographies
the answer to this is the top view
homography or inverse perspective
mapping makes an assumption that the
world around these cameras is flat
we can easily observe that this
assumption does not hold true in any
case whatsoever
the cars the trucks pedestrians and the
different monuments they have
considerable height in order for the
inverse perspective mapping to work
although we can get a top view of the
environment by applying an inverse
perspective mapping however the results
that we get from that technique are not
really accurate and useful for our task
hence we need such complex architectures
like unit xst
alright so the two components of unit
xst are not discussed now let us see how
these two components combine to give the
final architecture
for this network we are going to have
four inputs for the four different
images that we have as we can see over
here
we are going to have a similar encoder
network for each of these four images
as can be seen from the red lines
for the decoder we again have a similar
architecture however there is a single
pipeline that gives us the final output
the skip connections over here are what
makes use of special transformers
the four feature maps at different
levels are combined using spatial
transformers
each feature is first pass through a
special transformer and then these
different features are combined
this combination is then fed through the
skip connection
and this is done similarly for each
level of the architecture
all right so this is it for the
technical discussion of unit xst now let
us have a brief look at the
implementation and the results that we
get from training this network
all right so the link to this
implementation notebook would be
provided in the description box below
in the first section we have implemented
the different utility functions like
load image
and one hot conversion of the input
image in simple terms what one hot
encoding means
given a semantic segmented input that
has various different colors
we convert that rgb image
into a 3d matrix that contains a sparse
representation of the different classes
this representation is helpful for the
machine learning model to learn and
understand the data
in the next section we have the
different configuration parameters one
thing to note is that there are certain
changes that have been applied to these
parameters in order to obey the
constraints that are provided by us on
kaggle the image shape has been reduced
in order to get a faster learning curve
the batch size has also been increased
in order to get the same results
also the algorithm is only trained for a
total of 40 epochs whereas we would have
required to train 400 epochs
in this next section we have the
different data loader functions that
load the data for our machine learning
model
in this next section we define the
different network architecture
first we define the spatial transformer
next we implement unit along with the
spatial transformer extension
and finally we train the network
now let us have a look at the final
output predictions
just like before we have images from the
four cameras on the self-driving car the
front rear left and right
this next image is the output prediction
generated by our model
and the next image is the ground truth
bird's eye view image
as we can see the model has learned to
some extent to represent the bird's eye
view image
however there is some slight noise that
is present in the output
let us have a look at other images as
well
overall we can say the model has learnt
a representation of bird's eye view
image but it would require more training
to converge to more better results
all right so this is all that we had to
discuss for this unit xst technique
congratulations on completing the course
we together did seven different projects
and got to learn more about the
different concepts applied to perception
in self-driving cars
we did three projects related to 2d and
then did 4 projects that were related to
3d
in order to follow up with this course i
recommend that you go over different
data sets apart from the ones discussed
in this course
read and implement new research papers
related to perception for self-driving
cars or you can jump to and learn more
about different modules for a
self-driving car like localization or
motion planning as far as computer
vision is concerned you can also try out
different other projects like similarity
learning image captioning and generative
modeling this is all that we had to
discuss for this course and i would see
you in another video or another course
till then bye